doze deputados cada frame aqui então
gravar não andou se já não possui mais
gordura certamente que se o que é que os
inscritos têm que fazer o lado pessoal
que fala andar que sejam muito bem
vindos não mais um vídeo e ou mostrados
aqui um brinquedo incrível o produto do
ano que a matéria enviou para mim adoro
esses produtos agora estrangeira pronta
o play jogo é em crise vocês podem ficar
com toda a família com o pai o irmão
cuca eu acho que não vou jogar com o uso
que que neste vídeo assista o vídeo até
o fim vou jogar com o que também vai ser
bem divertido em que consistente jogo é
ganhar um cocô pelo conceito já ganhou
já agora deixem muito aqui em baixo
contínuo enquanto mas admite também eu
adoro este jogou com calma acabou né tá
incrível tenho um cocô em uma cena entre
o pessoal vai perguntar que esta voz
[Música]
misteriosa é quem será este ano a copa o
nosso gingado rococó lille
nós temos que lançar um dado de presente
pela sanita e depois de alguma maneira o
qual sai daí tá uma forma mas aqui
dentro da água e como melvin manual de
instruções ao limite ainda que ocorre
amauri e iaquinta muito engraçado essas
peças não só cocotá sorriso vai ser
campeão vamos um pouco mais misteriosa
vai ser só se estreou se eu voltar vou
lá ficou incógnito em baixo é que tem
200 piloto também tem que tratar isso
com muito jeitinho uso que estava fora
do dragão
na minha época eu achei as peças todas
primeiro passo que encaixar a nossa
caixa aqui
o orçamento tem umas fichas
aí o ou só colocar aqui com as regras do
jogo pessoal basicamente o que nós vamos
fazer é o meu adversário tem de contar
um dado uma vez que cada mesmo é pra
mostrar o lado erótico já que o
motoclista assim vai ser o número deixa
claro que é um então eu tenho que fazer
é sentir-se lista uma vez não aconteceu
nada sabe balançar por sua vez do down
só pra vocês verem forma a vitória o
coxa vai ser daqui vamos tentar fazer
com que isso aconteça
bom para quem atacar ocorre o
impedimento do ministério seja no chão
frio pra mesa oval uma ficha são 9h
ocorre no ar que perguntou pra ganhar os
palcos duas fichas no final cá é quem
tiver mais fichas portanto quem ganhar
mais um corpo no mar
gaia sob o sol em um brinquedo vocês
podem ver a forma como vocês quiserem
que as novas regras no entanto que ele
direita e agora vou chamar o pessoal nos
ajudar vamos lá fazer algumas rondas e
vamos ver quem cai desde já como embaixo
só tem vaga nesse ou eu ou b ou seja
como é tentar o ppi que ele está achando
a seguradora não só lá em casa já
comentou que é que vai existindo
portanto a partida já se mexeu mesmo
pedra
a pedra papel tesoura e papel a zona
euro eu não acho que nós dois vamos lá e
vir dos vídeos 221 iniciam uma fingida
exatamente um condição aqui outra vez
não vai sair agora sou eu
[Aplausos]
agora são paulo de 23 a 28 acima de tudo
muito perto e tentar pelo menos aqui
uau 2
no começo eu tinha uma necessidade e
constitui mais um evento só isso aqui é
concentração pode ficar aqui
concentração do ninja
sabe como é que é só o samurai ninja que
tem aquela concentração que sabe quando
vai ser cinco anos e nada nem tentei dar
um não vai sair por cima deu à luz a um
boom de silva não saiu e 2 o filho do
dono você não sabe amanhã o golpeou a
votar em mim há agora um ai ai 32 agora
3g
aí eu já saí um não em bull não é a vai
vai
a defesa do time muito técnico e um da
síria que agora sente 22 vezes na escola
nem só de fato já que fazia meu 2 e vai
ser agora não vai sair nada olha para
tentar ganhar o jogo que funcionasse de
forma imprevisível que será o oita 28
para o calor do sol o investidor dois
temas assim mesmo porque diziam que eu
matei o brinquedo é fazer um inventário
o que está aí há incríveis benson braga
para que deputados
eu sou a lenda com o pessoal é isso que
o povo chama tipo pois só um brinquedo
de 2007 vai ver o vídeo foi pelé tinha
eu disser alguma coisa assim
o que eu acho 10 10 quando toda a gente
brinca em diversão de pouso estava
tabosa cincos também construir que foi
um brinquedo que o quadro famosa porrada
que nós para destruir também tem de
fumaça infantil não seja nada desse tipo
de apoiar o jogo quando o guarda já
adotada ver e ser visto em público em
família é um copo iludir e tudo foi a
senhora quer salvar o produto 023 leu
por um júri mas não sabe respeitar mesmo
peso que quando perdeu em alguém que a
única coisa
tem também que ser um cão muito na toys
só espero ter mostrado aqui neste vídeo
muito obrigado a mattel também por ter
enviado e juca incrível brinquedo está
muito bom e não esqueça de deixar nosso
lá embaixo só firmei até aproximar eu
gostei do morumbi fez em campo
[Aplausos]